>> Sean: AS WE CONTINUE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY
FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI, I WANT TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING BECAUSE I WAS ASKING
YOU ABOUT PERKINS COOLEY AND YOU
SAID THE MONEY WAS NOT CAMPAIGN
MONEY -- I'M GIVING YOU A FACT
NOW THAT YOU DON'T KNOW, IT'S
NOT CAMPAIGN MONEY, NO CAMPAIGN
VIOLATION AND I SAID BECAUSE
THEY FUNNELED THROUGH A LAW
FIRM.
I THINK WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
$130,000 PAYMENT, IT'S A VERY
REGULAR THING FOR LAWYERS TO DO.
THE QUESTION THERE WAS, THE ONLY
POSSIBLE VIOLATION WOULD BE
WASN'T A CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATION.
WHICH USUALLY RESULTS IN A FINE
MANATT THIS BIG STORMTROOPERS
COMING IN AND BREAKING DOWN THE
APARTMENT.
THAT WAS MONEY THAT WAS PAID BY
HIS LAWYER, THE PRESIDENT
REIMBURSED THAT OVER THE PERIOD
OF SEVERAL MONTHS.
>> Sean: HE SAID I JUST THINK
THE REMEMBER THAT HE DID IT ON
HIS OWN WITHOUT ASKING.
>> I DON'T KNOW, I HAVEN'T
INVESTIGATED THAT, NO REASON TO
DISPUTE THAT, I LIKE MICHAEL A
LOT, YOU LIKE MICHAEL A LOT.
I FEEL VERY BAD HE'S BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY THIS.
THE FACT IS, TRUST ME THEY'RE
GOING TO COME UP WITH NO
VIOLATIONS.
PAYMENTS ARE PERFECTLY LEGAL.
>> Sean: LET ME GO BACK TO THE
MAIN CRUX, THE CRUX IS WE HAVE A
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT WHEN HE
SAYS WITCH HUNT?
>> YEAH.
SURE.
YOU CAN'T EXPLAIN IT ANY OTHER
WAY.
THERE NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
THERE WAS NO RUSSIA COLLUSION.
WE ARE NOW A YEAR AND A HALF,
TWO YEARS INTO THIS, THERE'S NO
RUSSIA COLLUSION, CASE OVERPAID
>> Sean: AND FALLING ALL OVER
THEMSELVES TO INVESTIGATE HIM,
THEY HAVE COMMITTED NUMEROUS
VIOLATIONS INCLUDING LIES,
CRIMINAL DECEPTION, OUTRAGEOUS
SEARCH WARRANTS LIKE THE ONE ON
COHEN.
HOW ABOUT WE GO BACK TO PAUL
MANAFORT, BREAKING INTO HIS
HOUSE?
HE WASN'T A VIOLENT CRIMINAL.
>> Sean: WHY DOES THIS END?
>> WHAT THEY DID TO MENA PU
>> WHAT THEY DID TO MENA PL
MANAFORT, I USED TO DO TO THE
MAFIA.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU SEE THIS
ENDING?
YOU TALK TO MUELLER.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO WRITE A
REPORT, THEY CAN'T INDICT HIM, I
DON'T BELIEVE THEY CAN SUBPOENA
HIM.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO WRITE
A REPORT, IF WE DO GET
INTERVIEWED, THEY WILL WRITE THE
REPORT BASED ON THE INTERVIEW.
THEY WON'T WRITE IT BY THE
HILLARY GUY, HE'S NOT A SPECIAL
PERSON, HE'S BEEN ENTRUSTED WITH
THE SAFETY OF THE WORLD.
>> Sean: IS THIS ELECTION IN
2018 GOING TO BE A REFERENDUM ON
DONALD TRUMP?
>> WERE GOING TO GO TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SAY YOU WANT
TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT?